est à présent monsieur philippe vigier
pour le groupe démocrate pour une durée
de 15 minutes
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
madame la présidente madame la première
ministre mesdames messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues vous voyez
un débat chers collègues de la nuit
baisse nous y sommes et les députés du
groupe démocrate ils sont prêts
aujourd'hui comme ils le seront toujours
tout au long de cette législature ce
débat vous l'avez provoqué en déposant
une motion de censure simplement
quelques minutes après le discours de la
première ministre pascal n'avait pas
demandé la confiance à l'assemblée
nationale
le vote de confiance il est lusage n'est
pas obligatoire et vous le savez bien il
me paraît important de rappeler à tout
le monde que michel rocard que pierre
bérégovoy qu edith cresson mais aussi
maurice couve de murville à droite n'ont
pas demandé la confiance à l'assemblée
nationale cette notion de censure
c'était votre droit doit déposer
évidemment nous ne le contestons pas
mais ce que je conteste c'est le fait
que vous ayez dit que la première
ministre était une anomalie démocratique
elle a été élue députée vous ne pouvez
pas dire le contraire est votre candidat
a été défait au préalable vous
reconnaîtrez avec moi que la
constitution de la vème république
garantit les conditions d'un débat
démocratique
d'ailleurs chacun connaît ici les
saillies permanent des insoumis contrer
cette constitution comme le faisait en
son temps françois mitterrand qu'il a
pourfendu toute sa vie avant d'en faire
un usage teinté de gourmandise
d'habileté lorsqu'il était président de
la république comme quoi le nouveau
monde rejoint l'ancien monde mes chers
collègues depuis le 19 juin dernier tout
le monde a dit qu'il avait gagné mais
tout le monde a perdu
personne ne dispose d'une majorité
absolue à l'assemblée nationale la
majorité présidentielle contre 44% des
députés n'ont qu'une majorité relative
elle n'a pas eu le résultat 2010 est
votre blog politique la nuque ps c'est
un quart des députés de cet hémicycle
le rassemblement national certes il a
multiplié par dix sur nombre de
parlementaires mais il n'occupe que 15%
de limites si la modestie me semble-t-il
doit être la règle pour chacun
surtout lorsque l'on voit qu'elle est
taux d'abstention aux élections qu'est
les taux d'abstention aux élections
législatives et présidentielles n'ont
jamais été aussi élevées qu'elles
défiance du peuple vis-à-vis des élus et
de vous mêmes nous sommes loin de la
situation chers collègues de l'adni
baisse de 1993 où il avait fait malgré
la bérézina pour la gauche huit cent
mille voix de plus que vous nous sommes
loin de 2007 où sous nicolas sarkozy je
me souviens qu'il y avait quand même 2
127 parlementaires de gauche olivier
haufor s'en souvient très bien ces
chiffres rappellent je crois que l'on
peut toujours avait beaucoup de talent
et beaucoup d'audace essayer de rendre
les défaites victorieuse mais les
chiffres sont en toutes lettres comme le
disait le regretté coluche et ces
chiffres sont implacables
l'utilisation des hologrammes
pendant la campagne présidentielle mes
chers collègues devenus pas ce n'est pas
possible pour compter les députés mes
chers collègues une motion de censure
c'est de démontrer qu'une alternative
politique est possible mais vous ne
l'incarné pas vous n'avez pas la
majorité absolue et vous ne pouvez pas
faire d'alliance improbable pour y
parvenir d'ailleurs vous n'y croyez pas
non plus j'ai lu votre motion avec
beaucoup d'intérêt uniquement technique
un peu jarre ppmc voyait le plus petit
multiple commun pas un mot sur la crise
sociale liée au pouvoir d'achat pas un
mot sur la pandémie que nous rencontrons
chaque jour pas un mot sur le soutien à
l'éducation pas un mot sur la transition
écologique pas un mot sur la crise
internationale alors si la première
ministre n'a pas demandé un vote de
confiance
même si elle pouvait compter
naturellement son soutien des trois
groupes de la majorité sans atteindre la
majorité absolue je ne crois pas un seul
instant que tous les groupes
d'opposition que tout oppose sont les
écoute mais beaucoup à rien tu es né
mélanger leurs votes dans le seul but de
faire tomber le gouvernement
certains y viennent de le redire à
nouveau comme les républicains ou leur
assemblée nationale avait d'ailleurs dit
avant même le discours la première
ministre qu'il ne voterait pas votre
motion de censure eh bien vous avez donc
offert un vote de confiance implicite à
la première ministre
mes chers collègues la situation que
nous vivons dans laquelle personne ne
dispose d'une majorité absolue c'est la
volonté du peuple français
aux élections l'initiative qui a voulu
cet état de fait qui s'impose à tous
respectons le peuple
qui quelque part n'a pas mis tous ses
oeufs dans le même panier et veut un
nouvel équilibre entre exécutif et
législatif
il appartient désormais à tous les
responsables politiques aux
parlementaires de penser à leur pays
plutôt qu'à leur parti en établissement
des compromis sans compromission les
députés démocrates s'inscrivent
pleinement dans cette démarche
comme l'a rappelé le président mattei la
semaine dernière cette situation
politique inédite signe le retour du
parlementarisme et conforte l'assemblée
nationale et conforte également le sénat
qui a plus son rôle à jouer c'est une
bonne nouvelle une belle nouvelle oui le
parlement est de retour
qui ici qui ici un moment de sa vie de
parlementaire n'a pas fustiger critique
et regretté les décisions qui arrivait
d'en haut ces amendements qui était
balayé ces articles réservés c'est
seconde délibération imposé personnes
j'ai connu ce genre de situation
avec nicolas sarkozy président avec
françois hollande président est sous le
précédent quinquennat le rôle du
parlement mes chers collègues va devenir
déterminant et l'exigence pour chacun
gouvernement et parlement c'est de
construire ensemble les bonnes décisions
comme vous l'avez dit madame la première
minute les collègues de l'anip s
déposant une motion de censure pour
démarrer cette législature mais vous
poser un acte de défiance pas simplement
au gouvernement mais au parlement lui
même
on n'a pas commencé qu on a zéro sur
vingt
et vous allez vous isolez car vous ne
serez pas suivie par les autres groupes
politiques
les majorités écrasantes mes chers
collègues conduisent souvent à des
formes de dérives comme on peut le
constater aussi dans les collectivités
locales le pouvoir absolu jean louis
bourlanges le dirait bien mieux que moi
n'accompagne que très rarement la
vitalité démocratique bien le contraire
chacun et va devoir plus accepter
écouter les propositions sans tomber
dans la démagogie et idéologie si je
prenais une image d'alpinisme cher à
eric woerth il va falloir couvrir des
voies nouvelles
la loi de raquette moins bavarde simples
compréhensibles
arrêtons de légiférer pour un oui ou
pour un non c'est sont entassés les lois
les règlements les normes parfois
inapplicables souvent inappliquées ou
mal appliquées aux derniers kilomètres
réservant les ordonnances madame la
première ministre aux urgences absolues
la co-construction l'initiative cher à
jean-françois copé pendant le
quinquennat nicolas sarkozy je n'ai pas
oublié ce n'est pas l'affaiblissement de
l'exécutif
c'est le gage d'une plus forte réussite
de l'action publique et de l'acceptation
par nos concitoyens des politiques mises
en place le peuple nous donne une
véritable chance inédite c'est celle de
rendre le parlement incontournable à
chaque parlementaire députés sénateurs
de mesurer la responsabilité nouvelle
qui lui incombe désormais à chaque
ministre ils sont nombreux cet
après-midi de comprendre que les
réponses qui doit apporter chaque jour
dans son département ministériel
il devra les imaginer avec les
parlementaires les élus locaux chacun à
sa place mais dans le cas d'une synergie
renforça triste cher aux médecins
infectiologues
non alors mes chers collègues au moment
où le parlement est de retour
après avoir parlé pendant des années de
l'affaiblissement du parlement
saisissons cette chance osons bâtissons
écrivons dans le respect de nos
différences de nos divergences les
solutions du quotidien nous sommes
condamnés à nous supporter comme l'a
très bien d'ailleurs dit claude malhuret
les prisons du groupe au sénat
les français n'accepteront pas le chaos
ils seront parfaitement identifié qui a
fait quoi qui a dit quoi et qui au final
est responsable d'une situation de crise
de régime mes chers collègues croyez
vous que les réponses à apporter pour
garantir le pouvoir d'achat des plus
fragiles actifs et retraités ne puce est
écrite à plusieurs mains en tout cas
nous on n'attendra pas la longue marche
qui démarre en septembre avec le c'est
mélenchon
croyez vous que les réponses à apporter
face à la pandémie qui est toujours là
il ya des solutions pour conforter le
système de santé soit si éloignées entre
les uns et les autres la réponse est non
croyez vous que les réponses à apporter
pour lutter contre le réchauffement
climatique
décarbonés nos énergies soient
totalement incompatibles entre les uns
et les autres je ne le pense pas croyez
vous que les chemins empruntés pour
atteindre le plein emploi permettent aux
entreprises de trouver enfin les
salariés qu'ils recherchent et sortir de
la précarité ceux qui sont depuis trop
longtemps cent dix lignes parallèles
c'est à dire qu'ils se croisent jamais
je suis certain que non au moment même
où je m'exprime à versailles avec les
salons de shoes france 100 nouveaux
projets industriels dans ce pays sans
nouveaux projets industriels et l'unc
est chère à mon coeur là ma
circonscription et je vous le dit avec
émotion
mes chers collègues croyez-vous enfin
que la réforme de l'éducation nationale
qui s'imposent pour redonner une
attractivité nouvelle assez métier
merveilleux de transmission du savoir à
nos enfants et à permettre aux
enseignants d'être respectés plus
soutenu n'appelle pas un sursaut
d'intelligence collective évidemment que
oui croyez ou enfin pour permettre à
chacun de vivre en sécurité c'est à dire
du poids bénéficié de la première des
libertés une majorité ne pourra pas se
constituer pour apporter des réponses
fortes est attendu dans les plus grand
nombre de nos concitoyens là encore je
m'adresse à vous les collègues insoumis
chacun prendra ses responsabilités et
ultra minoritaires seront ceux qui
considèrent que la police tue alors
qu'elle nous protège
mes chers collègues le travail
parlementaire de ces cinq dernières
années est émaillé d'exemples qui
démontrent qu'un chemin est possible et
je vais dire ça pour les petits nouveaux
le texte de loi sur la fin de vie
proposée par olivier falorni a permis
est à des députés de toutes sensibilités
de travailler ensemble et nous sommes
arrivés
maximino mort égard au vote de l'article
j'imagine que tous ensemble on ira plus
loin la lutte contre les déserts
médicaux
je vois yannick favenec je pense à
thierry benoit je pense à guillaume
garot et les propositions que j'ai
déposées elles sont extrêmement proches
la dea conjugale isation de l'allocation
adulte handicapé avec aurélien pradié a
montré qu'elle était beaucoup plus large
qu'un seul groupe parlementaire et que
cette erreur du quinquennat précédent
nous la rattraperont d'ailleurs le
président de la république s'est engagé
les petites retraites agricoles stéphane
des petites retraites agricoles monsieur
peu votre président chasse n est pas là
mais il me semble que le texte andré
chassaigne a suscité l'adhésion la plus
large oui ou non et là il est passé ce
texte est enfin caroline fiat qui est là
la vice présidente de l'assemblée
nationale
qu'a fait un rapport sur les ehpad dont
je sais qu'il est partagé par le plus
grand nombre et qui permettra demain de
servir à le doigt sur la dépendance mais
non même pas nos métiers par commission
je ne vous ai pas vus
jenny vous n'avez pas écouté qui servira
à nourrir la prochaine loi sur la
dépendance mes chers collègues ayant ce
courage de bâtir les compromis sans
compromission ces compromis
qualifié d' enrichissement de l'âme ou
d'outils de sociabilité par montesquieu
le courage
comme le disait sénèque c'est d'agir
c'est parce qu'on ose parce que nous pas
pardon que les choses sont difficiles mg
et il a rappelé le courage c'est d'aller
à l'idéal est de comprendre le réel
les députés démocrates ils sont prêts
ils seront proposant exigeants ils
seront vigilants notamment en matière
finances publiques et bienveillant avec
l'opposition ils seront facilitateur et
acteur chers collègues de la nuit baisse
il est donc indispensable
de repousser cette motion de censure
qui placerait le le parlement devant une
forme d'inaction alors que le parlement
a toute sa place qui conduirait le pays
à une crise politique mais surtout le
plus grave et tournerait le dos à la
volonté du peuple qui s'est exprimé en
juin dernier c'est la raison pour
laquelle mes chers collègues le groupe
démocrate ne votera pas vous l'avez bien
compris cette motion de censure
persuadé comme victor hugo que rien
n'est plus stupides comme vaincre la
vraie gloire et convaincre et je ne
désespère pas de vous convaincre
[Applaudissements]